today we're talking about next 21 data
loss protection and google distributed
cloud i'm jenny brown and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
google cloud next 21 is over but the
learning is just beginning with three
days of keynotes deep dives and
announcements there was a lot to take in
but don't worry if you missed something
the google cloud blog team is here to
round up our favorite announcements
check out the blog for more
data is one of your most valuable assets
so we're happy to announce that we're
making cloud dlp automatic automatic
discovery automatic inspection automatic
classification automatic data profiling
now available in preview for bigquery
you can enable cloud dlp across your
entire organization to gain visibility
into your data risk
organizations are looking to accelerate
their cloud adoption however some of
their workloads can't move to the public
cloud entirely or right away due to a
variety of factors to ensure these
workloads can still take advantage of
what the cloud has to offer we announced
google distributed cloud a portfolio of
solutions consisting of hardware and
software that extend your infrastructure
to the edge and into your data centers
check out the full details on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you